hey babe
[Music]
what's up babe
we just smoked sativia
or is it Sava sativa sativa
Stevia Stevia sativia
um we what do you think about artificial
sweetness artificial sweetness I heard
when I watch a documentary about how
they make sugar that actually right no
good no no artificial sweeteners are
actually better for you than sugar sugar
is one of the worst substances you can
put in your body true but I thought the
party line for a while was there was an
anti it was a backlash of artificial
sweeteners saying like oh maybe they
cause cancer or allegedly
according to the documentary I watched
yes was sugar
put a hit out yes no really I swear to
God it wasn't a hit piece and said that
really that that the article what how
what what does this scumbags do is they
write articles that have not been
peer-reviewed or researched for long
enough and then go with one thing that
happened in one part of the article and
then they put that out to the mainstream
and then people believe that's what
happened with cow's milk there's no real
reason that human beings need to be
digesting the milk of a cow
but one study said that it was good and
then you you say oh calcium and bones
and there's there's no
scientific reason why a cow and a human
should be sharing fluids wow
it's and this is what happens with sugar
sugar is the worst possible thing you
could put in your in your child's body I
do it daily
but and and and when I watch this
documentary
it just said that
foreign
I just want to phrase it right big sugar
it just it was a hit piece on artificial
sweeteners it was a hit piece on
artificial sweeteners and it just said
that the the article
that was reviewed by
not reviewed by the peers in the 60s
kind of [ __ ] on artificial sweetener
saying it's going to give you cancer
right because it gave one little mouse a
brain tumor but that brain tumor could
have been from from something else it
could have been from his years as a
carpenter right so so they said that it
actually does not cause cancer drinking
diet sodas you're making a reference
directly to carpentamize right
carpetromise okay I didn't know if you
just said Carpenter because that's a
profession that you thought of first and
maybe you weren't referencing carbonized
and if so that would have been an
amazing
do you ever think I I think about that
sometimes sometimes I I genuinely think
because you know Jesus was a carpenter
and his father was a carpenter and when
I see those
commercials
for mesothelioma I'm like Joseph got a
lawsuit on his hands yeah I think about
that like how many do you think let me
tell you something yeah let me ask you
asbestos
do you think do you think shout out
asbestos
what what diseases dis and disorders do
you think are here only because of
nuclear bombs
there's got to be some right I yeah you
think a lot I think you'd be remissed
remiss to find people in history who've
had some of the diseases we've had we
have and I do believe they're from
nuclear bombs I think I think that
Albert Einstein is cancer
he created it you think so well he's the
one who does some big words you got to
be ready Oppenheimer I meant to say
Robert Oppenheimer
for a paper that I wrote and I was a
history major okay the man who created
the Manhattan Project
Manhattan Project was a man named Robert
Oppenheimer for my entire uh
um college essay final essay to get a
major in history which I got I believe
in 80 on but I got 20 points deducted
for this mistake is every single time I
wrote Robert Oppenheimer I mispronounced
and I said Robert I put I put Robert
um
all that instead of Rob Robert
Oppenheimer I put Robert spunktemeyer
[Laughter]
company
Otis yes
I put Roberts
I in my head
because I used to eat those a lot for
some reason when I was because I wrote
that paper all in one city I put
Robert's spunked Meyer
created the nuclear bomb
and I mixed up Otis Spunkmeyer and
Robert Oppenheimer and I just said
Robert
Spunkmeyer and then she crossed it out
with a pen upwards of 50 times writing
Oppenheimer through my Spunkmeyer and I
proofread it I proofread it multiple
times and was like this is legit
I was like this essay slaps
over literally dude
[Music]
look at Bernie Sanders he looks like he
looks like a what's a dude um from
Pontiac he looks like Rick Moranis it
looks like he's it looks like he's like
it's like the start of Like a Porn cuck
video like where they're like wrapping
this guy up that's hysterical in Bernie
Sanders it looks like a machine of a
movie it looks fake
he's getting arrested look at the cops
it looks like that looks like a movie
uniform movie uh like uh cop uniforms
you know where do you think it happens
like
oh you know what I want to bring to the
uh bring to hey babe
um that I've been I have a um two things
I'd like to say to you yeah
one
um that I know we spoke about a couple
episodes ago but I think that
when you take a psychedelic okay or a
mushroom Ayahuasca anything I I am
starting to think that that is base
reality this is not base reality I think
that because of the level of
distractions that's a fine angle the
level of distractions we have the foods
we put in our body all the chemicals
that we pump up into our body which you
know naturally are legal and safe affect
our brain and Consciousness to a point
that we are not in base reality and I do
believe that the ancient Minds the
ancient Egyptians maybe even the ancient
Italians that had all these wonderful
works of art The Da Vinci's and all
these beautiful things that we Marvel at
how did they do that how did they figure
that out I do believe because their
brains were closer to functioning in the
reality that acilocybin brings you to
and that was their base reality
what was seeing things is this is this
um is this
something that you have read about and
agree with or is this something that
you've you've you've articulated these
thoughts that you're having right it's
something I've read about because that
was that was that was a very well laid
out argument it's something I've read
about and then kind of tried to put my
own do my own didactic research and say
this is what it is and I will tell you
this I want to make this statement right
now into the camera I truly believe that
the ancient Mayans
saw things in colors that don't exist to
us
just yes to us and I think when you
watch a show like Ancient Aliens
and you want you watch that show
and you they're trying to figure out
how they could have done this and why
they drew that and is this a space
helmet I think it's simply the fact that
they were not distracted they were not
bocked down by caffeine they were living
life they were every single day they got
Barefoot and plugged their feet into the
sand onto the floor got charged up
through the Earth they only put products
that the Earth could Supply no man-made
food no man-made chemicals nothing in a
lab right only things the Earth gave you
and when you only take from the earth
the earth only giveth back and what the
Earth giveth back to you is like whoa
It's Like Whoa and it's seeing
vibrations and colors and looking up at
the stars and literally unlocking the
universe with your eyes because people
can't understand how the Egyptians were
able to get such an angle such a perfect
angle of a pyramid that can't be even
replicated by Modern Machinery today and
I thought well maybe they just looked up
at the universe and without any
distractions at all said I am one of the
universe and the universe gave them the
answers on how to do this and I don't
know that our brains I believe that we
are the most technologically advanced
cannot debate that but I do not think
spiritually we are the most advanced I
think if anything we've regressed and
that's why it's very difficult to look
back in history and figure it out
wow dude I gotta tell you for someone
who's High
you did not stammer in in what you were
trying to say and communicate at all you
you led every single sentence cleanly
with another sentence you didn't you
weren't at a loss of words you didn't
have trouble pinpointing exactly what
you wanted to say and you said it so
measured like it was it had been written
that was an excellent I think you were
one as you go back and look at yourself
and you're like that is a well-spoken
man that felt like a freestyle dude that
was off the Dome should I speaking of
freestyle let's watch Brandon sagalo
you were telling me that he wrapped I
had no idea Brendan sagalo comedian uh
extraordinaire
dude will be a guest will be a guest of
hey babe uh one third of the um can't
wait I always forget what's the name of
their podcast again what's the scenario
what's the scenario because it used to
be Irish goodbye but now it's what's the
scenario oh yeah one-third of the with
of course Mike Cannon and Mike Feeney
and then Brendan sagalo uh who now raps
that's great it
this is a four minute song
called
oh it's timeout is this comedic
at times respect his art but no no what
is his angle
pimp pimp can you can you elaborate on
what Brandon sago's rap angle is is he
is he straight As far as I got the story
from him he's out of rap now but it's a
world he got sucked into for a few
months and they actually took time away
from stand up he got very lost in his
work and he said that he couldn't really
figure out what he what it want his rap
name to be and he slaved over it and
then I said very quickly what about
Brendan sagaflow and he said damn
that was it
he was like that was it
that's good oh so so genuinely he was
trying to pick up being a hip-hop artist
or being more apparently his name is uh
seg daddy the god
and just because it was he's because he
loves it and he got interested in it he
said I'm gonna give this a whirl I think
he's that's I applaud that I think what
he said to himself
is
he got to I think a point in his
spiritual journey
that's very difficult to do here
in today's world because he's not
ancient he's not an ancient Mayan right
from what I know yeah I think he said to
himself
I've said this before but it's thinking
about I'm thinking about it now in the
words of Winston Churchill yeah I think
he said you know what
Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it's the courage to continue that
counts
that's what I think sagaflow said to
himself what did this sativa unlock in
your brain I think you are quoting
Churchill to the letter
Winston Churchill If You're Going
Through Hell just keep going
that's what he said yeah
so is that good advice
I don't know
I'm an executive by day and a wild man
by night
okay so this is clearly this is a joke
my name is Mike and if you're watching
this tape smoking your cigarette press
the fast forward button because I don't
smoke and I don't like anyone who does
I'm not afraid to get sand in my tuxedo
if you're right since the Florida
Strawberry Festival
I'm looking for a trendy girl with a
simple smile
um
I took a sponge ball and I was cleaning
out this girl's ear I'm looking for the
goddess
are you the goddess
[Music]
[Music]
is crazy so let's say I'm on a trip
she
what do you think yo sag Daddy I was
closing my uh I wasn't watching this I
just wanted to hear the flow I I didn't
realize that that was the video at first
I thought it was just a sketchy then the
concept of the video is very cool sag
daddy the god Cutlery music video yo I
kind of like this [ __ ] song come on
man
killed it wow
shout out you said would take daddy sag
Daddy to God
why not go comedy and music
I think honestly man I would love to be
able to sing r b
I don't want to rap
what would your single be of your first
album some type um
sometimes my the name of my first track
would be like girl I want to love you
like a Mayan
yeah
no you know what always had the dream of
doing dead dead serious I want to sing
the national anthem uh you mean the Mets
game right I could sing it at a Mets
game all right I want you right now okay
I want you to sing it I want you to sing
it but I want you to sing it truly truly
promise
the best that you possibly can okay
should we get a test run right now yeah
should I try to do it off the top of my
Dome or can we pull the lyrics up don't
make the lyrics a problem get the lyrics
if you need the lyrics all right my what
I want to focus on is if you truly this
we did this on we did this on as a
punishment on Joker's last season okay
we for charity we had Joe who's doing
the pandemic we had Joe Gatto
um we sold tickets to live to Joe Gatto
singing The Wind Beneath My Wings to the
best of his possible abilities okay so
we had like thousands and thousands of
people streaming and he was in a studio
and he came out like a tuxedo and velvet
in front of him and he had to sing for
charity like the the best he possibly
could and it was so ridiculous dude he
said we could oh I don't think we could
play you probably played him oh we can't
play Jokers yeah it was really really it
was really funny dude because the funny
part is the earnesty and you truly
trying okay yeah okay all right
right up here right
what's up everybody you know I'm high go
to christycomedy.com for tikiwickies I
got a brand new hour of stand-up
material
um we got September 28th in Madison
Wisconsin September 29th in Milwaukee
Wisconsin September 30th in Chicago
October 1st in Minneapolis we've also
added a show in London on October 6th at
um the theater there
and we got Belfast has got some tickets
left and I'm high so christycomedy.com
look up for all the rest of the Tiki
wikis that you see your city's on there
go find it Philadelphia go find it
whatever and then in the south at in
December Charleston Charlotte
New Orleans
Houston I'm going I'm going to a hybrid
City between Charlotte and Charleston
called Charlotte
but it's all on there babe also
Montclair I'm coming home
yeah
christycomedy.com
all right well I'll just go over the
hills tonight
I start uh I start on the road again
October 14th starting some [ __ ] October
October 14 was stirring [ __ ] up I'm
going through to the new year and this
is who's on the thing right now we got
Hamilton uh Ontario and Toronto October
14th and 15th second show we had in
Toronto thank you Toronto uh how about
Richmond Virginia and Hershey
Pennsylvania on October 28th to 29th
Hershey made of the second show thank
you I might want to go to the Hershey
Park there go have you gone for the uh
they turn to Hershey Park into like a
Halloween thing around your time you're
there oh my God I'm there like a Fright
Fest oh wow that's great I'll tell her
she after oh two shows though Same Day
next year Day live
all right Richard Virginia that one
Capital yeah how are they over there
have you been there never been to
Richmond Virginia but I'd love to go
because I do need a picture with this
steak camp
you that's one of the ones you don't
have I don't have it well you want to
call me to Richmond I'm there on October
28th okay and let's just figure I would
go
I would love you to come
let me know I think I have a show though
okay
uh November 11th 12th and 13th we're in
Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham
see I said that Birmingham not the UK no
Alabama's also
Alabama it's not oh my God Atlanta we
added a second show thank you Atlanta
and they don't like when you say
hotlanta what venue is it in Atlanta uh
Center Stage Theater good theater is it
I don't know okay
Knoxville Civic Auditorium though is a
mask it's massive but I just did I just
did not a whole bunch of uh
Tennessee and now I'm like I don't know
are people going to come because it's so
close to each other come to Knoxville
yeah they'll come in Knoxville okay if
you do promo with Johnny Knoxville okay
oh I'd love that do you know him no
uh yeah uh all right I'm gonna be in
Louisville on November 18th at
Evansville on November 19th uh and I'm
really excited Louisville I haven't been
there so come on through and then in
December this is it we got December
second third and fourth I mean
Jacksonville Tampa and Orlando Tampa
we're in the show in Tampa so thank you
Tampa I appreciate you Tampa Tony Tampa
Tony December 16 17th and 18th I'm
finally coming out all the way to the
West Sacramento San Jose and Santa Rosa
California and everything's available
now at salvocanocomedy.com and one more
thing
don't forget about the new merch please
order merch okay go to our websites
merch links are there hot merch t-shirts
sweatshirts stickers what else we have
everything dude everything no pressure
um no christycomedy.com
salvocanocomedy.com and uh links in
these videos the links are in these
videos all right and yeah baby we got
all those merch up all right thank you
wait wait is something in your mouth no
do you have mint in your mouth no oh
okay why I didn't want you to sing with
the mint there's some in my does my
mouth look swollen no it looked like you
uh made a gesture that to me notified
you might have had a mint in your mouth
and now you're about to start singing to
the best of your ability and I didn't
want that to hamper it yeah
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light
what's so proudly we hail
at the twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the
perilous fight or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly
streaming and the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in air
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there oh say does that
Star Spangled
Banner yeah it was
the land of the free
and the whole
of the
bridge
that was beautiful how bad is it bad
never heard anyone probably that doesn't
sing sing that long to their genuine
best effort that was my best day it's
always it's so fun I think people more
people should do that for themselves
because it's it's genuinely hilarious
it's so it's so pure and it's so
genuinely funny like more people should
be like play that game with their
friends be like all right sing this song
to the best of your ability you cannot
laugh you can't laugh and you really
gotta try because those notes some of
those notes you're hitting were insane
why don't we just make it like a fan
challenge
just have the fans do the national
anthem yeah sing the national anthem
of your respective country yeah sing the
national anthem of yours regular country
to the best of your abilities
uh into camera and and right uh what do
you want to call it
uh hey babe national anthem by the way
just real quick trending I want to say
happy birthday Jungkook oh I think is um
a big Korean um
K-pop she wants it's not it's it's today
the day we're filming so by the time it
comes out I want you and everyone who's
listening to which John cook a happy uh
belated birthday so if we could start
the hashtag happy hashtag happy belated
birthday John Cook day
so that and then also hashtag Nash hey
babe national anthem what are they what
are they getting for this just we're
going to retweet those shows a piece of
clothes yes I was going to say hashtag
Hey babe national anthem just like we
did uh hey babe hey babe uh worst hat
stupid hat hey babe stupid hat hashtag
Hey babe stupid hat who who remember you
have to you have to reenact your
favorite hey babe scene for this one all
you need to do is to the best of your
abilities filmed in front of an audience
could be of your family of your friends
but there have to be people that are in
the room on video watching film uh sing
the national anthem to the best of your
ability uh from your respective country
tweet it at hey babe national anthem hey
babe national anthem post a video on or
post a video on tag us at hey bay pod
and we will give you
um we will give you well we'll certainly
play them we'll play it and I think why
don't we give by the way submit for both
if you want
by the way is there any more clothes you
don't like we could give the fans stuff
you don't like
clothes just like your hat
oh [ __ ] yeah why do we got tons of that
so why don't we do that yeah I could get
stuff from my closet I don't want
yeah let's do that hell yeah rather than
giving it all away to the Salvation Army
yeah let's give it away to the hey babe
Army
yeah let's give them an article of
clothing that will sign hashtag
hey babe stupid hat hashtag Hey babe
national anthem and let's give them not
even merch it's I'm not because you can
get the Merch online I'll talk about an
oracle of clothing from our closet that
we will sign and give to you
I can't get it anywhere else but our
closet okay
so and what was the prize for the big
win the Hat the Hat okay they went they
won the shitty hat okay well the hat is
part of the show now yeah but you know
like whatever something from your closet
autographed is probably
a good motivator as well I would think
if I was a fan of something
what is on your mind right now Sal
something that
really like resonated with you in a
positive or negative way what's like
what's on your mind what's something
that Mo that what's something that's
moving you an emotion that you can
articulate
Jesus Christ like anything that you've
been feeling over the last week the last
day
in a positive could be positive could be
negative could be deep could be surface
there really are no wrong answers it's
like meditation you just let it happen
do you want me to go first
I feel like you're sure I can just so
like I've
like the emotion that I've been trying
to
articulate lately and and where I think
I'm feeling is conflicted not conflict
but conflicted I feel in many aspects of
my world from everything every it seems
like
everywhere everything I do from making a
decision to order food to
what to wear
it feels like
I have my feet in two places and I'm
straddling Two Worlds and what I need is
to pick a side
I've been trying to pick a side and
that's what leads to the depression
that's what leads to the anxiety is is
if you can just get to a place where you
can have two feet on either side of
whatever the fence May hold you will
inevitably be better even if you realize
you chose wrong at least you won't be
conflicted and being torn down the
middle you'll be whole
so is there anything happening to you
like that
no
okay
the tea training for
look at this guy
what the [ __ ]
oh my God
this is from official deflex one look at
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my
God look at that the flexibility is next
level
the timing of you
throughout that conversation
did you could you imagine your first day
back at the gym that's what you [ __ ]
do
that's very difficult what he's doing by
the way
is that little Nas X
he's his he's
front over back
front over back he's
he's not hitting his nose he's
[Music]
down
[Music]
there guys
look at the crack of his ass
it almost looks fake why is he doing it
the [ __ ] is he training for
where is his where are his balls in a
scenario look at his ass crack
oh it's funny man good for this kid
don't try that at home how do you
how do you find out about that you guys
cloud
no that's real
come on come on
that's wild babe
it's got to be some type of thing though
with like it's always they always they
always say oh it's because of this dust
or sand or air pollution there's only I
hate that there's always an explanation
could have been a Benetton publicity
stunt yeah exactly
that could have that's actually what we
confession we did that to sell the hey
babe rainbow merch that's it that's
right I have never seen uh have you ever
heard or seen a rainbow cloud before I
have not until this moment the only
things I've ever really the only
immediately when you say that when I say
the word rainbow what's the next word
that pops in your head right
really no mine is what cookie
every single time since I've been a boy
you say rainbow in my head I go cookie
wow you know I don't you know I favor
calling them seven layers so that's why
that's not like at the top of my Rolodex
there I have a question for you guys if
you have any superpower you could give
yourself your own superpower
what would it be
I think we should I mean it's always
between flight flying and invisibility
for me
mine would be what do you need to be
invisible for you know
and in many ways in many ways it could
be fun but I mean at least for the first
five years of my comedy career according
to my bank account I was invisible right
right I wasn't on the grid I mean I was
invisible you already achieved that I
achieved invisibility yeah flight I
believe I've I believe I'm flying right
now I was gonna say I'm high as I can be
right now
um plus I've been in Airline so it's
something that I think you can't feel at
all I would like to be
um I would like to be electricity
I'd like to be electricity
wow that's what I'd like to do be
electricity be able to use electricity
and harness it and use it you know how
how does it manifest itself from you
like shooting stuff out of your hands
yeah or or just just you're powering
electromagnetic electromagnetic you
could put lay your phone on me so who's
that that guy exists already right this
he's a villain somewhere well there was
a woman who got struck by lightning
there was an article about this I
actually just saw it this woman who got
struck by lightning and then something
happened when she got struck by
lightning that it kind of made her a
conductor for electricity and she was
struck by lightning upwards of 50 more
times in her life to the point now where
if it's even a cloud in the sky she
cannot go outside all she has to say I
swear to God Justice specifically coded
room in her house that doesn't conduct
electricity or else she would get struck
by a lot she will continuously get
struck by light she's been struck by
lightning up like upwards of 50 times
every time she walked outside it would
find her crack the door open like yeah
yeah be like she's made a claim that one
of the they were sitting in like this
room that didn't have the conductor
thing or whatever she thought she was
safe and then the lightning made like a
like a circled bolt shape and hit her
like it will it finds her
that's insane dude uh just the last
article I read about someone that got
struck by lightning said that they died
they died yeah Direct Hit but I thought
that was uh
I thought the norm was like I've heard
of a lot of people getting hit by
lightning and not dying what's it nice
you could I thought I'd actually feel
like I heard more stories about people
surviving getting hit by lighting than
being killed by lightning what's an
interesting phenomenon is when people
get struck by lightning on their entire
personality changes or they get you ever
see those that guy got struck by
lightning and then he just constantly
paints and he has no he has no artistic
I think one time we talked about we
talked about something have you ever
seen a guy that can make sculptures at a
microscopic level that are so well
fine-tuned and crafted like you pull
that pull up man who can make
microscopic sculptures
man who can make microscopic
sculptures and then I want to talk about
how I believe the mind is actually in
the stomach
okay
you you too uh you are a bit of a
philosopher
from a philosopher I think I just
listened to a lot of Joe Rogan Clips
okay and then I just try to do the
research on my own got it
but I mean look at this guy this is this
is like the modern day da Vinci
this is Da Vinci in blackface
this is the kid by the way who I saw at
the
Soho House in in Staten Island
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is
this guy
[Laughter]
this guy
I think it's about 15 microns I'm not
sure a man with a British accent like
this man with this British accent
you can't go oh yes he's just sounds
smarter yeah 100 it's just a man with a
British accent
because but look at how crazy that is I
bet you put it a motorbike that's the
size of a human hair how does he do that
and your movement
very very minimalistic you have to move
in microns but I know
when you get the Queen of England
writing you a letter saying that much
she appreciates what you've made oh my
God which is a crown which I made for
the queen how did you even again how do
you even get into this I think he was
struck by lightning
no I'm serious I think that's what
happened to him
sculpting away
it was a natural ability
oh okay he was struck by lightning as a
child
for ants
well that's wild awesome that's crazy
number five no man do it
that's the sound of Shopify
Shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources one tweets are for big bears
and that's the Bizness so upstart
startups and establishes business the
business this is a like can control
everything everywhere synchronize online
and then in person sales believe me the
Ching is the sound of another sale on
Shopify
I love it for some reason I love hearing
that sound effect uh scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility uh we started out selling uh
in the beginning some stuff honestly I'm
gonna be honest with you right now I'm
still selling [ __ ] on the side on
Shopify
Shopify Powers millions of businesses
from first sale all the way to full
scale synchronize your online and your
personal sales reach customers across
social networks they have a suite of
Integrations for all the apps Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock Pinterest uh it
grows with you Shopify the possibilities
all of it is powered by Shopify go to
shopify.com hey babe all lowercase
for a free 14-day trial and get full
access to shopify's entire Suite of
features grow your business with Shopify
today go to shopify.com hey babe all
lowercase right now shopify.com hey babe
that's
[Music]
it yeah 300 000 Partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose for
me National restaurants like Popeyes
Chipotle Cheesecake Factory that's right
other essential items not just from
restaurants you love drink snacks and
other household items and under 60 mins
you looking like a snack doordash you're
not just getting things you love you're
supporting your community too which is
what where is the main thing the Dashers
they're the people driving around each
purchase provides a new opportunity for
everyone involved because with doordash
there's a neighborhood of good in every
order for a limited time our listeners
can get 25 off
and zero delivery fees on their first
order of fifteen dollars or more when
you download the doordash app and enter
the code hey babe that's 25 off up to
ten dollar value and zero delivery fees
when you when you first order when you
down on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store
hey babe put 25 percent of your first
order with door Dash subjects change in
terms Supply I'm using door National for
dinner can you pause it just one second
and then I want to finish this but it's
so wild this pimp and I were talking
before this we were talking before the
the show started we believe that autism
that autism like right now we're humans
at one point you know factory setting
1.5 that autism is 2.0 that actually
what being autistic really means is
you're actually more have a futuristic
brain like you're omor from the future
you're like all these people like in
autism is not a it's almost an upgrade
not a downgrade in other words like we
talk about it as being on a spectrum but
most people who are genuine artists and
genuine savants like this man usually
fall somewhere on a spectrum like him
saying he has autism that it's almost
like his brain is doing things that are
blowing our mind so how is autism a
defect if anything it feels like an
upgrade and pimp and I talked about
really hyper hyper Progressive in one
area yes autism but autism
only really started coming about like
being diagnosed after the nuclear bombs
were dropped so pimp is saying that when
we drop the nuclear bombs it caused a it
caused a rip in uh in a Continuum in a
parallel unit and that when we see UFOs
it's not well I listen to Tom DeLonge on
Stevo's pod right and he gets paid by
the government to study UFOs he's like
legit and he had a theory that uh the
nukes reached parallel universes and
that between each universe is like a
veil
and that the aliens were actually kind
of Time Travelers rather than aliens
that they just time travel
from a parallel universe
yeah
yeah that means time travel is possible
that's what they think well
theoretically theoretically we will live
to see injection
we will live long enough on to our
civilization will go long enough to have
those UFOs yes
theoretically if time travel exists
what's happening right now if time
travel exists it's been created already
if it exists it's here right then it's
here already because if it's the future
that's what begs the question too is
it's well everything's happening now
there is really no the only reason why
time is not real time is a man-made
construct it's all it so it doesn't
exist we call time time and but it's
just not real this is not what the
universe is giving you the universe says
everything's just happening now because
if you take how long the how big the
universe is and the you know just to
make it easily to digest how long we're
here time you know it it really comes
down to like you know 500 years ago was
like a second
so
it's all happening now and that and that
that actually that actually makes me
less anxious because it makes me feel
like well if I truly am of the universe
and I'm the same material as the Stars
Then I know I had to be something before
and I'll be something after and it won't
it doesn't actually ever end I wish I
could believe that
so where do you think that feels good so
I just wish I believed that so where do
you think your energy goes when you die
what happens to the vessel that holds
your soul
I don't know because the soul is real it
has to be
do you think that
we're the soul you what you're really
speaking to is my soul
okay my body is just like a vessel it's
just a meat vessel but the soul is what
I believe the soul is what's born and
put in a factory of you know of bodies
the bodies is the least important thing
all right
it's the soul
I hope that's true but going back to
that the mind now is being science is
starting to
find out that the Mind most of it exists
in the gut and that's another reason why
they think people thought differently
and painted differently and had
different Visions is because they were
eating different foods and bacterias
that we don't eat anymore that have all
been sanitized out so their gut health
was different therefore making their
brains and Minds different and look at
we the chemistry of a human being in
1400 is radically different in the
chemistry of a human being in 2022 it's
a different type of thing they may
genuinely have seen different colors and
different shapes and I'm talking about
they are a different operating system
they might even be a different species
that just has the same meat vessel isn't
it crazy that
okay isn't it isn't it crazy though
isn't it crazy that if they were that
you know spiritually connected and
finely tuned living off the Earth The
Way We Were Meant To Be prior to us
doing all this [ __ ] now and this isn't
it nuts that then that's like the best
way to be but then the life expectancy
was like 14 years yeah it sucks like if
you made it to 30 years old they were
like well you're a little [ __ ] you
didn't you're not you didn't die in war
right you got no disease like it was
very rare it was I think when they say
like oh Socrates died an old man they
met like 27 right you know like that's
probably what it is because you were off
to fighting in Ward 13. I mean you were
you know you see in the second Game of
Thrones episode that just came out the
new one they're trying to marry a girl
marry a girl marry a girl off who's 12.
that ain't nobody batting an eyelash
nobody but not online so what happened
um so NASA just revealed what black
holes sound like and It's haunting let's
hear a black hole yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I
think they said it was like gas or
whatever
traveling
kind of nailed the space sound effects
of movies I guess
that shit's eerie
I yeah man I don't um
I hate looking at stuff like this
although it's I do love it I hate but
it's too it's too for me I I I'm like
this is the most interesting thing in
the world this is fascinating and then
the rest of the day I'm like thinking of
myself in this very existential like way
well like honestly look look go back to
that picture of the black hole I'm not
even honestly trying to be funny but
like when you look at the stars when you
take a microscope and put it to like a
stardust it looks exactly almost
identical to the cell circulatory system
of a human being like so that's where
they come up with the thing of like oh
we come from that because it's mirrored
and imaging that like that looks like in
an anal cavity or a throat it just looks
like it so it's like it's all part of it
it's like you know
because my question to you is is this is
is um
my question to you is this
when you die
okay when you die
is it possible if everything actually is
happening now
that you just maybe go to another time
because memories
that's been very close to being
scientifically proven it is a hard
hypothesis right now that most the
scientific Community agrees on memories
they believe are now inherited
through birth that you inherit your
mother and your father's certain
memories and your great great
grandfather's memories and it is all
passed down through the cells this whole
idea that everything comes from the
brain is being shattered and they're
trying to do so much more research on
the gut on the cells that that actually
is the same transference of of imagery
or memory like we said on a few hey
babes ago when that woman had to get her
organ removed and then replaced with I
think it was a kidney
to get a kidney transplant and it was
Chicana a kidney of a man who was a
house general contractor she started
doing all her general contract work
yeah
pimp we talked about it
yeah
she was a she was just a regular woman
in her 40s that started putting up
sheetrock putting down flooring he was
packing up
truck
oh God yeah oh my God it's real funny
that's so funny yeah
yeah it's real
yeah
pimp Google organ transplant woman
becomes general contractor
wait okay go Google
um
Google uh organ transplant woman woman
becomes woman I don't know organ
transplant woman woman uh does good at
buildings
laughs
[Laughter]
like how he would have written it
no it's true though I saw it we watched
it pimp right already on hey babe
oh god
um okay so wait so
wait why do you keep pulling up Anthony
Davis
oh I hung with him recently to Anthony
Davis he was on the show he was on the
show he's in the USA olympic he's an NBA
champion too he won with the Lakers
didn't he was he on the NBA winning uh
Team I don't know the championship
winning team
because
no did he win with them
oh yeah
yes he did okay that that yeah so what
happened so what what what was he like
what did he say oh he's the best he's so
so cool so much fun
we had a lot of last is he tall in
person
he is so freaking tall dude it's wild
but uh yeah they they did I got but he
actually messed with me what'd he say so
I had to do a series of challenges like
so so I called you know how I would
sneakers I like sneakers I love snakes
they got
um a pair of sneakers the new Travis
Scott like Jordan Ones high and low and
that though two those two things
together as well over five thousand
dollars they bought them
wow and I got to uh the the on set and
they had them on a podium in a glass box
and they said you could have gonna go
through a few rounds of things and each
each time you're gonna be able to either
do something to the sneakers all you
have to do to yourself and if you do it
to yourself we won't do anything to the
sneakers so at the end of this you could
end up with actually an awesome bit
at the end of it you could end up
winning you know these sneakers are
probably like 5 500 bucks so I was like
oh you kidding me I've been wanting
those but
so the first thing was uh it was not
that bad they were like we can cut the
sneakers cut the tongue off the sneakers
or cut your pants right now into like
little Daisy Dukes
so I was like fine so they cut my pants
off into little Daisy Dukes instead of
cutting these things you can see both of
my Jaden tattoos right it was funny I
was like I look and then uh and then the
next one is all right you could drink
a mixture of minestrone and clam chowder
out of one of your shoes or out of this
old used uh fireman's boot
so I I did I drank out of the [ __ ]
boot right I had it yeah right it was
gross I believe it it was probably left
over like
bad stuff in there yeah the firemen used
to [ __ ] in their boots yeah
third one
uh I could do something to the soul or
give me can't give sign my soul over to
Murray
okay they had a contract drawn up and
they had a notary public there
and so I signed my soul over to James
but what does that mean
I don't know right I truly don't know
but he he owns my soul right now right
like it is a legal document right so he
healed my soul he's gonna hold it over
me I guess I don't know yeah but I sold
it myself next one was my mom comes out
right they they sit her in a chair right
next to the sneakers they say he could
dump a full bottle of red wine on the
sneakers or a full body red wine on your
mother's head
yeah on your mouth and it was your
actual birth mother yes my mom yeah yeah
talk about Sal tell me about a time yeah
just one time you got stuck focusing on
problems instead of solutions and how
did that situation go better with a
different mindset I want you to talk to
me about that uh it happens to me daily
so I can't even pick one
and yes if I had a different mindset I
probably could avoid a lot of it
well I'm gonna
give you the keys to a different mindset
and those keys unlock a little door with
the front right on the window a little
sign it says Dr Leibowitz better help
that's right it does it says better help
because my actual
counselor's name on betterhelp is Dr
Leibowitz I asked him if it was okay to
say his full last name he said no
problem so Dr Leibowitz if you're
listening and I think I think you
actually are because you are making the
decision if you want to put me on
antidepressants or not
um so you're watching anything I put up
I want to say thank you from the bottom
of my heart for helping me through uh a
lot of things that have been going on in
my life better help worked for me it
will absolutely work for you I can
guarantee it because I don't have to
fight through anxiety to get out the
door and go to an office I do it right
from the comfort of my own home right on
the computer and I turn the camera off
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible and affordable
let me tell you something else about a
help I'll tell you Bachelor the
therapist after filling out a brief
survey uh you can start talking to
someone within 48 hours you can switch
therapists anytime when you want to uh
to be a better Problem Solver therapy
can get you there visit visit visit
visit visit visit visit
betterhealth.betterhealth.com hey babe
today and get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash a babe that shit's p
this episode is brought to you by Ridge
wallet the ridge wallet holds up to 12
cards plus room for cash there's over 30
colors and styles including the Hennessy
performance the carbon fiber and the
burnt titanium uh I got these products
delivered to my house a couple of weeks
ago and I absolutely love them I'm using
the wallet right now I'm also using this
dope pen that they make uh and and I
also have a really cool keychain holder
and actually I think either in this
episode or the other episode I was
wearing their t-shirt so big fans over
here the walls have over fifty thousand
five star reviews the durable material
means each while it comes with a
lifetime warranty the rich team is so
confident that you'll like it that
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days you can send it back for a full
refund if you don't love it it's made
with RFID blocking technology that
protects you from digital pickpocketers
and here's a special bonus for our
listeners with every dollar spent on the
website before September 30th you'll be
under to win a brand new upgraded Ford
Bronco or 75 000 cash if you prefer
window will be announced in October to
get your Ridge wallet and to enter for a
chance to win a Ford Bronco go to
https colon forward slash forward slash
r-i-d-g-e.com slash hey babe and use
coupon code hey babe to enter yeah and I
was like oh my God and I just felt so so
bad I felt so you dumped it on your
mother yeah oh my God I felt felt so bad
wait did the episode come out already no
it's like he's this season 10. we filmed
this this comes out like like next year
oh my God I pulled it on my I felt so
bad dude we have so many pictures
because everyone was like couldn't
believe we were gonna do it Anthony
Davis is laughing so hard he's like
jumping in the air laughing and I just
have a bottle of my mouth that's all
over her and I'm like literally almost
crying like I'm so sorry when was she
like Sal don't do this don't do this no
she was so cool she she just looked at
me and I felt so bad and and at first
she was like don't do it but then she
was like ah she's literally on camera I
think she went half
and she's like dude I want you to have
the sneakers that made me feel even
worse so then what was a fun way that
she was like do it do it what I did it
that was the last oh no the last one was
hot coals
could put the sneakers on my feet and
walk over the huckles with the sneakers
on or I could walk Barefoot what'd you
do and I did Barefoot hot Cults and you
got the sneakers
I got the sneakers okay I burnt a part
of my toe I got the sneakers and then
they're like wait one more thing they
take me through a door and it's a gym an
in the basketball gym
the Boys and Girls Club were there and
they had a tournament and it was a free
throw tournament they were all with
their parents there's like 25 kids like
25 30 parents whatever it was and who
as I'm walking through they tell me all
right this is the last thing this is a
local Boys and Girls Club this kid just
won the sneakers in the Free Throw
Contest and I walked up and the father
and the kid was standing up there
everybody else was in the crowd and
they're like ladies and gentlemen the
guy donating the sneakers
and and Anthony Davis so me and Anthony
Davis walk out I'm whole like at the
sneakers are there and uh
and they go all right Sal you could give
the kid the sneakers or you could tell
them he doesn't get them
and I stuttered I started and everything
but I I told the kid I changed my mind
you don't get the sneakers and then the
parents were like what and they just
started like yelling because they they
genuinely were like I saw booing and
everything
and I just took the sneakers and I
literally just like I literally like
just be lined out of the gym
took his shoes off and gave it to the
kid because you would make your mother I
mean how upset would your mother be like
you that's what I'm saying that's
exactly what I said to them I go how do
I not I did all those things how do I
not go through with it now I I I could
have not done that to myself right now
to this day does not have those sneakers
no I have um are you sure we can give
away endings of the episodes
two yeah what are we gonna do whatever
it's not like it's a
suspenseful drama Thriller that's wild
man that's the thing is sometimes you
know
I got those shoes
they're worth 5500 bucks a pair of shoes
like that will you ever wear them
outside I do it
I do it not I have some pairs I won't
wear outside usually like when they're
that much money I I probably won't so
what will you do with them but like you
hold it's like Bitcoin yeah yeah
although I'm sure the bottom will fall
out of this one day and it'll be worth
nothing and I'll it'll be a losing well
then you have a good pair of shoes yeah
but really the shoes are made for ten
dollars you know right they say for a
couple of hours a day try to walk on the
earth barefoot
that's I mean who can do that people
live by the beach I think that's a big
plus right go put your feet a lot of
times people what they would do is
ancient people and like shamans and
stuff they just bury their feet and they
just sit and put their feet sand over
their feet and they just stare there for
10 minutes and they charge
from that that's what it's like
basically right yeah because you have to
start to think about what about when you
go on vacation it's a very like you know
relaxification you're just like in the
water and in the sand the whole time I
come home charged up well yeah and I
think too now what's starting to become
pretty evident is like Jesus or whoever
the Creator was didn't intend for people
to be inland
he they wanted everybody by the Sea
that's why they built the sea you got to
stay close to the Sea because all the
things to benefit you and nurture You
Are by the water you get in trouble and
you go too far inland
China Kansas
when we make a connection with the earth
when we ground through barefoot walking
there has been found to be a reduction
in white blood cells and an increase in
red blood cells which hints to better
immunity barefoot walking has been shown
to help increase antioxidants reduce
inflammation and improve sleep sure but
what about the foot pain
so what are you gonna do it's another I
walk around Barefoot for on a hard
surface like a like cement or whatever
for more than a couple of minutes I'm
dying this could be one of those
articles instead dead that is not
peer-reviewed same thing as big sugar
this this might be this might be Bigfoot
I remember those that that whole that
whole uh
it's a dad joke that's great I love it
that I love a dad joke Bigfoot
you remember the craze of the shoe that
wrapped around all your toes that was
horrible and they were saying that's
that's what they were saying they were
saying That's the version to of how to
like walk Barefoot but with protection I
think that shoe was horrific hysterical
ridiculous people wore that shoe all the
time
I thought it was like in a way
it's probably like it's probably really
racist yeah I know but it looked it
always looks so so weird maybe even
pretentious I don't know I don't know
what the word I'm looking for is but you
want to get a pair your toes going in
the [ __ ] yeah and then what happened my
toes cross over each other so I would
have to every time I put on my shoe pull
my toes apart and put them in I I know I
have a broken left foot I honestly think
I have two broken feet
I really do so I don't know if I my my
feet can conform
to a certain way I have mastered the art
of walking around trying not to get hurt
I know how to walk you yeah
I also at some point it's like [ __ ] your
gadgets [ __ ] your [ __ ] your improvements
once you just learn to live with what
you got not everything needs to be
improved radically all the time even the
iPhones it's like just pick a version
and stay with it yeah just stop after
13. or 12. whatever just shut not
everything needs to be constantly
updated one every five years
how about that yeah I mean or like why
does this urge to always get better at
stuff like just be content with what you
have like every generation's got to come
and how do I be the best how do I be
number one why do you have to be number
one do you know how much pressure comes
with being number one that you tell
every every coach does every athlete you
want to be number one well I got to be
number one why why why do you have to be
number one explain it explain the
benefits of being number one other than
unbelievable pressure a an exorbitant
amount of people now trying a gun for
you because they want to be number one
and then your ultimate fall from number
one
making you inevitably depressed because
we can only really try to stay in the
moment and if we're being coached all
the time stay in the moment stay in the
moment stay in the moment well there
will be a moment where you will fall to
number two and you'll be depressed had
you never been number one in the first
place you would be happier healthier and
probably alive longer because nobody
wants to take what you have heavy lie
the crown is this is is a saying that
exists for a reason you don't actually
want the crown when you try to come at
me with your
[ __ ]
about what something you are mimicking
that you heard some
professional speaker say on tick tock
about how you need to be the best and
how you got to be number one and how I
don't buy it you know why because I'm
happy with who I am I'm saying my meat
vessel that I'm carrying around today is
enough
yeah I I I took in everything you said
when you go to other countries
okay United Kingdom they don't act this
way get this get those of you a
motivation though they're striving for
being the best that kind of helps your
like you excel in the journey
it's a motivator but and then I and then
there's also impure motivations not
necessarily pure but people do some
stuff for money you got me I don't know
why I'm thinking of fighting now
Fighters striving to be the best and the
short shelf life is in the Fall From
Grace but you could apply to anything
but I'm thinking of of like UFC people
and stuff like that but you got to
strive to you got to be careful if you
want to try to do the best that's okay
but it has to be the best version of
yourself not better than someone else
you have to be the best you well that's
not how sport at least works
well maybe individual Olympic sport if I
was king of the world I'd cancel Sports
really yeah really it's out why why
especially you're a big fanatic loves
sports I just um you don't think it's a
please expound
I think that it's
dramatic it's impressive it's
competition
it's you know spirited you know it makes
money
it drives definitely you know helps City
evil true competition evil
so talk to me then tell me why
because entertaining
watching people do something at a high
level
competing
I think we're past it
as a people I don't think we need to do
it anymore
are you a lover of sports you're being
serious I think it's just the same thing
over and over and over again you win the
championship then a month goes by and
then you create this fake thing again
and then win a thing that never mattered
in the first place again
it's just a waste of your time
you should be instead of playing sports
why not have all those athletes get out
there get Barefoot plug into the sand
right get on a higher consciousness
let's get on a higher level spiritually
it's fake it I can understand if there
was one one time one time every 50 years
you're playing the sport and you know
it's going to give your continent the
the advantage to get water and food then
fine by all means but this thing it's
like what is the point of a season what
is the point oh you won the championship
in 2012 who cares it's irrelevant like I
just had a 38th 38th birthday who cares
but
it's irrelevant
you've been hanging out with them it's
irrelevant
um
I think when you're talking at least
about not necessarily exercising but
when you're talking about competitive
Sports they only exist through
competition
you know what so so they would that
would be wiped at your your eliminating
competition I believe right you know
what man let's bring back Sports
already I actually think after talking
it through what an idiotic idea it is to
cancel Sports
you need Sports
they promote a healthy lifestyle usually
promote a healthy lifestyle discipline
my daughter could use with some sports
people Bond over Sports the only sport
my daughter's good at right now is
crawling out of her crib and falling at
her onto her head is she the number one
hopefully my day she will be hopefully
one day she will be let's see what high
she can CL climb up and fall out of
Walt Disneyland tell me about it
oh yeah
Disneyland I believe
although it's fun for all ages
you get excited you get some endorphins
ultimately I don't know that it's leaves
our children uh
happier healthier and in better
condition from when they first went in I
think that
a rat race I think that things are
overpriced I think that
it puts children into a space of
like this reality that's kind of not
what they'll grow up in
but what about just creativity and
fantasy and fun
I don't I don't think going to
Disneyland
I think
I think
the ultimate thing you can do for your
kids and be completely selfless is take
them to Disneyland I don't think that it
gets any harder on a parent than taking
children multiple children under the age
of seven to Disneyland it sounds like I
don't think it gets any harder than that
it sounds torturous it sounds insane I
I'm as impressed with that as the guy
who's drawn sculptures on rice
you think that's one and the same pretty
much
pretty much
well I guess I can't really it sounds
like hell I guess I can't articulate why
I don't like Disneyland I was able to do
it a couple hours ago but now I can't
I just can't tell you why I don't like
it okay but I'm I guess I guess say that
I'm happy my kids liked it but what I am
actually proud of is that we told my
kids that we were going to take them
back to Disneyland two times in one week
we're gonna take them back to Disneyland
if they listened and then they didn't
listen that night and then we actually
followed through and took Disneyland
away from them and they I agree and they
cried
for five minutes and then we told them
Disneyland is gone but not your day so
you kids can go in the pool and have fun
there and then they jump for joy put in
their bathing suits and stayed in the
pool for 12 hours right so you kind of
realize your kids never they don't need
Disneyland right Disneyland needs them
yes
it's true and also maybe I think a lot
of people a lot of people are living
vicariously like they're like let's go
to Disneyland because they want to go to
Disneyland
yeah I would say that the most problems
when I was at Disneyland was my family
were the adults not agreeing over what
section of the park they thought they
said the kids wanted to go to AKA what
part do you want to go to right yes okay
yep
what was your favorite part of
Disneyland yeah Space Mountain
space that's the roller coaster in the
dark right fully in the dark yeah Space
Mountain and then also going into the
Galaxy ride phenomenal it's in the Old
Tower of Terror uh 3D thing let me no no
I'm not kidding the screen and then it
goes up goes down my daughter was
screaming she didn't know when we were
waiting online she's not understanding
the physics of it yeah she goes is there
a drop I was like it's a little one
because I thought that it was and then
it shoots you 200 feet into the air at
the speed of light rather it brings you
right back down I'm not lying this is
100 true I told this pimp ttj was there
even my daughter someone in our ride in
our cubicle fully [ __ ] their pants
no no a full [ __ ] on the floor out of
their shorts I on my children they fully
[ __ ] in their pants when you got out of
the ride the woman opened the door she
goes she goes all right guys you know
that was whatever Guardians of the
Galaxy and then slowly put her mask up I
swear because they all were wearing
covert mess but she he fully 100 [ __ ] in
his pants and you know Jerry was with it
she goes oh my God he goes I think
somebody [ __ ] their pants
TT Jerry and then Delilah was Delilah
was like Daddy it stinks and everyone
was and everyone was getting off the
ride I swear to God except these two men
sitting all the way in the corner of one
of of one party all right because you go
in with like 12 people but it was a full
[ __ ] in the pants wow
that's unbelievable it was and it was
not a fart it was an undoubted undoubted
no but you saw the two men sitting in
the corner I think they were a gay
couple two men sitting in the corner
um not moving and you knew that there
was [ __ ] in that so you know you could
tell you could just tell yeah yeah and
how I also know it was [ __ ] in the pants
because the way you come out you can see
the line which the line is put is moving
pretty constantly yeah because you can
fit so many people and they got and the
line was at a complete stop
what does that mean because they had to
clean the [ __ ] off the floor before they
could load more people and so the line
was out of completely you're convinced
that not only did he [ __ ] but the [ __ ]
fell out of his pants he shut down the
ride there's no way no he [ __ ] his pants
and and me and Jerry and my daughter and
my stepson were kind of like being like
was that a fart and it was it was fully
[ __ ]
out of his ass down is like on according
to the Galaxy
Guardians of the Galaxy
what is did a tourists get diarrhea on a
roller coaster that Splash 14 people oh
God I I would have to think I would have
to think if I went on a roller coaster
and somebody diarrhea [ __ ] in my face
and I had waited two hours at what point
do you just you have to kind of make a
split decision and say well I can't get
out of this so I might as well just
enjoy the ride
and just like the diarrhea don't try to
move out of the way just keep your mouth
shut yeah just and just try to get
whatever you can for them close your
eyes and just let it kind of happen
that is the most Zen that's the that's
the the most advanced way of looking at
that situation that's what the Mayans
would do that's what they would do
that's what they would do oh man well
well you know what it's been this has
been
hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey baby